I finally did get cast as his brother
and Baker boys and he looks at me about
a week-and-a-half couple weeks before we
start the job and he says you know you
should do something to change your
appearance I said what what are you
talking about he says no no this guy you
know he's kind of a struggling guy you
want to make him vulnerable I think you
should have a receding hairline and a
and receding back here and back your
head I said no thank you
no and he said no he says I think it'll
be great for your career challenge you
yeah and then he said and he said and as
a matter of fact and we'd been partying
having a few drinks of wine and stuff
and he says this is getting late at
night and he says in fact I'd like to
cut the back of your hair right now
so stupidly
I let him and I think he did it with one
of those buzz things you know and just
destroy the worst I thought you were
gonna tell finally what happened the day
before we start shooting you know about
maybe a couple of days before we started
shooting he met with the the makeup guy
and there's a you know wonderful
technique where you you know you you
know you cut you with a straight razor
you cut your you know your what do they
call that widow's piece over the widow's
peak is just the intent receding
hairline then you go in with a blade and
you very gently and delicately remove
hair so you just have like single hairs
left long single hairs and then you
maintain that look by taking one of
those electric razors with a screen on
it and you just go over like this and it
doesn't cut the long hair and it cuts
the the very short hair and the makeup
man says you know and every morning you
come in and we'll do this you know this
procedure bogos yeah
so that day the first day of shooting he
comes and he's got this dislike a
jockeys cap on or something like this
and there's very serious expression on
his face and I said my guy said what
what he says look what I've done and he
takes his hat off and there's just one
side got that going and then they had to
match it but it ended up looking like a
very bold move bold choice
you know the because my my brother his
public persona is very do defied now you
know because it's a good he's very
relaxed and he's kind of like this well
as a matter of fact he's very much like
our Father and his craft he's a
perfectionist and it blew my mind on
that first day he's talking about I came
into the makeup trailer and there he is
he's in there you know long before I got
in there and he's got his hand out like
this
and that makeup person is like doing
something on the top of his hand I said
what the hell is that and he kept saying
no no move it a little over this way a
little bit and he was schooling the
makeup artist where to place this
freckle on his hand
because that he figured as a piano
player they're gonna see the freckle and
he wanted to establish it early on I
couldn't do it